non ce n'était pas le Radeau de la
Méduse ce bateau qu'on se le dis au fond
des ports dis au fond des
ports il naviguait en pèpénard sur la
grandmare des canards et s'appelait les
copains d'abord les copains
d'abord c'est Fluctuat ne iture c'était
pas de la littérature non des plais au
jeteur de sort au jeteur de
sort son capitaine et ses matelots
n'étaient pas des enfants de salot mais
des amis franco de port des copains
d'abord c'était pas des amis de luxe des
petits castors et Polux des gens de
Sodome et gomor
Gom c'étit pas des amis choisis par
montaig
Labie sur le ventre il se tapaient fort
les copains
d'abord c'était pas des anges non plus
l'Évangile il l'avait pas lu mais il
s'aimait toute voile dehors toute voile
dehors Jean-Pierre Paul et compagnie
c'était leur seule litanie leur crédau
leur confit et or au Copains
d'abord au moindre coup de trafalgard
c'est l'amitié qui prenait le car c'est
elle qui leur montrait le Nord leur
montrait le
N et quand ils étaient en détresse que
leurs bras lancés des
SOS on aurait dit des sémaphores les
copains
d'abord au rendezv vous des bons copains
il y avait pas souvent de lapin quand
l'un d'entre eux manquait à bord c'est
qu'il était mort
oui mais jamais au grand jamais son trou
dans l'aaue se refermait 100 ans après
coquin le sort il manquait
encore des bateaux j'en ai pris beaucoup
mais le seul qui est tenu le coup qui
n'est jamais viré de bord
mais vir
de naviguer ton père pénard sur la
grandm des canard et s'appelit les
copains d'abord les copains
d'abord